[Music]
Justin Bieber who didn't give it up for
you
and I would think if you are a fight
champion Justin Bieber's opinion would
mean a lot to you but he insulted you on
Twitter after the fight and said that he
still thought that Connor was the better
fighter and didn't give it up for you
yeah that make you feel the way it works
is the guy who won is usually the better
fighter but yeah I'm a dancer winning 1
under those circumstances but that's the
way we went down but yeah he put his
opinion out and I heard about it and I
was like whatever but then someone
posted on social media a picture of a
few slapping it at me slap yeah take a
look at this
[Applause]
yeah yeah
garden yeah but yeah I saw I saw that
and that was really funny to me so I
posted the picture yeah and when viral
everybody saw it everybody's all about
it and then it was as crazy cuz I was
out here in LA and I went to a club and
like four days later and then
everybody's coming up in the club like
hey justin bieber's over there he's over
the corner like they were coming at
coming through my hey what's up you know
Justin's here and I might like throw
this big big big fight supposed to go
down with me and Jesse they want to have
that fight would have gone hey when I
got Jesse hey what but I was like all
right leave Justin alone it's not no
problem but they night him and he had a
little crew with him
bunch of little Bieber's yeah okay they
came in found me it came up on me them
and their boys like way I had a crew
with me to those I came up and I don't
know they were like he was like right up
to me they say hey what's up man like
whatever you know it's all good let's
squash the beef man whoo
otherwise I be Forex right here I like
it's all good I have no problem with you
Justin Bieber that's just what I'm
saying I have no problem with you just I
don't want nobody great sex you know I
got no trouble with you Justin Bieber
they've been boxing these stuff too so
you wanna watch out for him but yeah
maybe my gay yeah so we have so you guys
took a picture of you guys together I
think this is you squashing the beam
yeah there he is yeah
let me ask our angle though he cool man
now not gonna roll up Joe got he's going
here got pulled out
you